hey there and welcome to the motion
science video podcast my name is cameron
and today i am speaking with shannon
wilkerson shannon is a motion graphics
designer he's a visual effects artist
and a video editor based in denver
colorado he's got nine years of
experience
shannon has had the opportunity to work
with some of the most innovative clients
and artists from around the world
his favorite word is in the english
language and it's
phantasmagorical if i pronounce that
right
which means having a fantastic or
deceptive appearance as something in a
dream
or created by the imagination i
absolutely love that
this world this word is the perfect
description of why he is passionate
about motion design creating beautiful
imagery to galvanize the imagination is
what shannon
looks for
lives for sorry about that
welcome to the show
shannon wilkerson
hey cameron hey great to have you here
man
thanks for having me i appreciate it
definitely definitely so for those of
you who don't know shannon has already
put together
a workshop in proflos and he's got
another one on the way and hopefully
he's got several more after that
shannon's really good at
3d art from what i've seen and what i've
experienced from his work
so shannon can you tell us um
tell us a little bit about
um what you do
uh in the world professionally right now
sure uh right now i am a senior motion
designer for an in-house design agency
for
um the television
kind of distributor dish network um here
in denver colorado so i've been doing
that for about three and a half years
i started there kind of as a mid motion
designer and then about a year and a
half after you know doing
multiple jobs um
i moved up to a senior position
i'm one of three motion designers on the
team there are like 60 people in my
department which is our design agency
and i'm one of three so i feel pretty
special about that um and mainly what we
do i do work on a lot of the broadcast
spots that they do
but i also do
a lot of their in-house work so if their
accounting department needs some kind of
um video for any type of event that
they're doing there's a lot of
conferences that a lot of departments
are a part of so they'll need some type
of hype video i'll put those together
for them also so
nothing i mean that's the gist of what i
do for the company but it involves a lot
of design and animation and stuff like
that so so is it mostly are you mostly
working in 3d or 2d or is it a combo
combination or what
what is that like well it's a
combination of both and it really
depends on how far i want to push the
project luckily i'm in a position now
that i get to decide what direction i'd
like to take it my creative director
kind of just gives me liberty just to go
go with it so it really depends on the
timing and how much time do i have on
the projects which usually i don't have
a lot of time um how much time the
budget and then if i feel i could pull
it off and if it works for the
particular concept that the client is
going for so i try to push as much 3d as
i can because i feel like i'm stronger
in that but a lot of the times because
of timing it just doesn't work you know
with rendering and stuff like that so
you have to compromise yeah yeah so what
like on a typical job that you're
working on how much time do you have to
turn it around
so if i do let's say if a
um for instance dish latino is one of
our one of the big departments within
dish and they do a lot of broadcast
spots that um so if they come to me and
say well we need a 30 second ad that
entails these price points we're going
to shoot this type of video and we want
these type of graphics they'll usually
give me about a month for something like
that um usually depending on how
i guess involved it is um it can go
longer if it's more detailed but um
other things like if i'm doing any type
of social post or
or any type of digital work is what we
call it in our department it'll probably
be anywhere i mean it would be anywhere
from two days to two weeks and that's
probably the most that you would get for
something like that
so when you're working on these these
spots are you is there a creative
director above you or are you having a
lot of creative input into like what the
graphics are looking like or how does
that play out
yeah so i have a creative director who i
speak directly with and we also have our
main art director and then we have the
director of the department and then we
also have our project managers and our
account managers so they all have input
on
um the project but mainly i'm in charge
of what it looks like my creative uh
funny enough the person who is my boss i
actually got him hired because about
seven months ago my boss ended up taking
another position at another company
and i didn't want the scene that that
position because i knew the type of
responsibility that it entailed and i
still wanted to create not go to
meetings all the time so i actually
ended up getting him hired um to take
that position and he fully trusts me and
so does the director of the the entire
department they really give me liberty
to do whatever i want
not to say that that wasn't earned it
took a while for me to actually get to
that point and prove myself but after
being consistent on multiple projects
they're like yeah shannon just go with
it we know it's going to come back okay
so right if any if it sucks we'll say
something so that's that's pretty much
how it works now so and they do when it
does suck it it does sometimes yeah you
find out about it right
exactly so how long did it take you to
move up the ranks to where you are today
so i started about three and a half
years ago and i moved into my senior
position in a year and a half oh wow
yeah
so then do you have a team that works
underneath vue
i do not i i don't have anybody that
answers to me um
no
yeah
mainly i'm just there for like if any of
the um so the other motion designer
designers on the team are more beginners
um they haven't been doing it for more
than one or two or three years or so
so they'll come to me for like um tips
on like you know technical tips on like
after effects or cinema 4d even if
they're using it most those guys don't
even really touch cinema 4d as much
they're mainly just after effects
so no i don't really have like i'm not a
boss of anyone right so yeah right
so
with these with the beginners like what
what are their main tasks because i know
there's there's several people in
proflos that are beginner level and
they're always wondering like okay if i
was to jump into the professional world
and let's say they were to get a job
with like the company you're at with
dish like how what would they what would
their tasks be
usually um if we're coming if you're
coming in as like a
lower level motion designer animator
you'll probably start on social projects
because
social is so fast we do so much of it i
mean i i couldn't tell you how many
times they post on social a day it's
absolutely insane and all that has to be
animated but it's never really
too involved it's some text animation
and stuff like that so it's a good way
for them to actually learn
um before we actually give them an
actual big project where you have to you
know have store you have to have flushed
out storyboard style frames we we have a
whole process where you know you
you come up with your concept and when
you pitch your concept to the client you
have your style frames ready and then
once they're done with those then you
move into storyboards we don't like to
put
too much of that onto somebody just
starting out we want to make sure that
they have the hard skills down first um
before we start moving them into you
know doing more concepting um but
one of the individuals that i started
working with three and a half years ago
his name's rolo he had not done any
animation he's he's much older than me
he's not much older than me i think he's
like 41 or something like that
and uh he had never really done much
animation but before i started they
didn't really have any motion designer
so he's starting to learn and in two and
a half years he's in two years he's
doing full flush broadcast
advertisements you know he spent so much
time
learning and like staying late after
work and taking courses and stuff like
that that it blew my mind how fast he
advanced um because he wanted it so bad
you know and now he's doing full-fledged
um
projects now so it's great
yeah i find that
those motion designers that have that
that drive to really push themselves and
to learn on their own and to really just
like you know for me it's like you know
of course i'm going to promote courses
and memberships i mean that's why i'm
here but like you know for me even
personally it was all about just putting
in that extra time and just figuring
things out and just diving into these
programs and really understanding what
they can do you know
so what
talk a little bit about like
how did you get how did you become the
motion designer that you've become like
what was your process what was um tell
us a little bit about your a little bit
more about your background
yeah absolutely so i kind of i kind of
started i'm kind of a late bloomer as if
if you would call it like so i went to
college at adam state university
and i studied i got a degree in
marketing and then i got another one in
advertising and another one in general
business but i didn't even know so i was
a triple major and i had no idea that
this field even existed and i just ran
across it and my junior year in college
um i started seeing um
like i i got my first computer i had
never owned a computer before and i got
i finally was able to get the money to
buy one and i was online a lot and i
started seeing all these different like
3d artworks and all these different
animations and then i ran across the
site creative cow i don't know if you
were oh yeah yes and then that just blew
me away so i had no idea how to use the
software
um
no idea like even what direction i
wanted to go i just knew that i was
really into this i was like this is
amazing you can learn how to edit and do
all this stuff had no idea so after i
graduated
immediately after i graduated i enrolled
in the colorado film school now when
what year was this
so i graduated in 2006 from my first
undergraduate degree and then i moved to
then i went to the colorado film school
and studied post-production because at
that time i was like editing i want to
be an editor that's it that's me you
know
and so i went i
went balls in you know hardcore like
ready to go and uh i did very well but i
started i i started learning
other aspects of film like visual
effects and then that took me so then i
just went down this whole tirade of just
focusing on visual visual effects and i
did that for a very long time
um but i wasn't quite hitting the market
like i wanted to i wasn't getting any
jobs or anything because i'm in denver
so the
opportunities for something like that
isn't really that great but because i
knew how to use after effects motion
design was just a pivot you know i could
be like hey i could do that i can
animate that text but i kind of
i really sucked that design i didn't
have any design fundamentals at all so
that's where i struggled there so for a
while you know i was working um doing
some freelance jobs you know two 300
bucks a pop um but mainly working in the
restaurant industry um as a bartender
and a server and i was also a uh i was a
customer service representative for
netflix for two years um but at one
point i think it was when i was 29 i
told myself it's like okay
i'm either going to start
pursuing this like i wanted to like i
want to become who i want to be or else
it's not going to happen i'm going to
still be doing these mundane jobs
so i took six months off
and i learned i basically studied
probably about 10 or 12 hours a day for
six months just learning
cinema 4d getting deeper into after
effects and just kept going um
taking i don't know man i don't know how
many courses i've taken over the years
it's pretty crazy
so after a certain point like i say i've
been doing motion design for nine years
but i've only been doing it well for
four really truthfully um because for
the first five years my work was
subpar um but i got better you know and
that's when i started getting noticed
and when i turned 30 i got a job at this
company called fnw media and this was
like my first like
major job that i had ever had other ones
were for companies that ended up failing
and stuff like that
and they really liked me i did well
there but it just didn't pay enough and
my skill level was so far above what
they were asking me to do i got really
bored
um
quickly so and i noticed that my work
started to falter too my personal
projects and stuff like that i started
not caring because i was complacent
that's when i left and i started working
at dish that's when um
i started looking at the work they were
doing and saw that they were trying to
basically build in
a in-house design
department so that they didn't have to
go to outside departments or outside
companies to actually handle a lot of
that stuff because it was getting much
more expensive
and i wanted to be a part of that and
they welcomed me with open arms they
were super super like supportive of like
my past work even though a lot of it was
experimental
and they actually ended up paying
because i told them one of the biggest
things
i struggle with is my fundamentals in
design i'm just not really strong with
it and they actually paid for me to go
to like design boot camp
and once i took that that's when my work
really started to solidify because now
my technicals you know abstract
animation and 3d skills were now
um i guess design sound if you will or
they were i don't know how i would put
that but um
from a designer standpoint they made
sense now you know typography all that
stuff and i started understanding that
stuff a lot more and how important it
was
so that's how i am where i am now um
yeah that's pretty much the story that's
awesome
um okay so
how do you
what
led to you getting hired by these
companies was it your real was it your
personality i mean what was it
i think it was um
i don't think it i think it was my work
for sure uh i'm a i'm a fairly
introverted person
i do reach out to companies and you know
different
artists that i admire to get advice and
stuff like that but i've never really
actually asked for a job from anybody or
anything like that so how i found out
about the dish network
position was through a company called
creative circle or creative group i
don't know if they have something like
out there in florida but it's basically
an agency for creatives where you know
companies like dish and stuff like that
they can go through the agency and find
creatives to come in as opposed to
trying to recruit them themselves uh
just makes their the overhead a little
bit
uh less overhead for the company itself
um so that's how i found out about that
so um you know i looked on glassdoor saw
that the job was open i applied um they
called me in the very next day
interviewed me through creative circle
and then dish was like okay if you guys
have vetted this guy now we want to
bring him in the next day dish brought
me in and i was hired on the spot so
after the interview so oh wow it was
crazy how it happened i was like wow
that was nuts it literally took me like
two or three days to find a job that's
pretty cool that's awesome
so um i think i'm very lucky in that
sense too but i also think that
the the company and the individuals that
i work with and for are so like
just so open-minded and you know ready
to move forward and try new things and
you know you know break the mold think
outside the box that's what they're all
about so
i think i fit well yeah i mean it sounds
like it um
so okay so where i mean i know that you
don't want to say anything that's going
to like jeopardize your your
you know current job with with dish and
dish isn't going to see this but where
where do you want to ultimately end up
with your career
yeah so my biggest goal my main goal is
that i would love to be
there's two things that i want to
one or the other i want to pursue
because i know i can't do both i either
want to be an art director at a really
nice studio like my dream job was always
to work at like the mill or digital
kitchen or something like that that you
know i know you used to be there too
some some place like that that's that
has that high level kind of
motion design or something um or i would
like to be a technical director for like
um
particle simulation so
uh for like ilm industrial light magic
or or stardust or companies like that
you know where i i'm in the i'm so far
into the software that i'm writing code
and making software inside of software
to help you know junior artists uh do
their jobs better so those are my two
those those are my main aspirations that
i want to accomplish within the next
four or five years
um and after that i haven't i haven't
really decided i really really want to
get back into film because that's where
my passion lies and i would love to be a
director um i just don't know if
i i realized in film school that
directing wasn't for me i was the guy
that liked to be you know sitting in
front of the computer and you know
editing clips um so i don't know if that
has changed as i've gotten older um
because i i would like to direct someday
and like tell my own stories gonna be
awesome
so
in terms of like if you were to get a
job with like ilm and and go that route
would you be
do you like do you see that kind of work
having like where you have to be placed
back in l.a or do you see it going
remote i know we're in a interesting
time right now where a lot of people are
going remote
i think remote is
probably the smartest thing um and the
reason why is because when you're when a
company says that they can't hire you
because you know we only hire people who
come in i think you miss out on a lot of
talent when you do that
um and i know the overhead is huge i
mean my the company i work for
they i literally work in a fortress this
place is massive and i'm like man the
overhead cost just to have people to
have a place to come
is
it's got to be insane so i think i think
it's i think remote is the best way to
go especially for creatives because
even even taking you know two hours out
of your day just to commute to work can
can break your process and can and break
your thought process on that so
it's a little it's much harder for me
like when when the kova thing started i
felt like i was more productive for one
of two reasons one i had two computers i
had my work computer and my personal
computer so i could do double the work
and two
um i was able to i didn't have to worry
about getting up and ironing my clothes
and then getting into my car at a
certain time so i could hit traffic at a
certain time making sure i got breakfast
before before i go to work you know i
can just sit down eat breakfast and then
you know get to work so i i felt like i
was more productive on top of that too
when you work in an environment like i
do in a corporate environment there's
just tons of meetings and you can't get
around them and that really dampers the
amount of time that you have to work on
a project well when you're working
remotely those meetings aren't as often
you know so
and sometimes i think those meetings are
a little bit unnecessary i think they're
just fluff uh
so
yeah i think remote i would love to be
remote
all the time if i could but i also
wouldn't mind like if i got
hired at ilm i would not or pixar or
whatever um i would not mind walking
into pixar every day
not at all so i'll take that hour
commute if i have to that's great um so
working remotely do you miss like that
um like when i went remote that
sometimes i would miss that synergy of
having another creative next to me or
around me and just like bounce ideas off
um do you miss any of that or is that
something that you weren't really into
no i definitely missed that that's
something that i feed off of i think
most of my work come draws from
outside entities like inspiration
references and stuff like that and
the people that i work with are very
inspiring people and they have great
ideas so it does
you i don't think you would miss that as
i don't think i miss it as much as like
like it's never going to be there again
once we go remote i don't think of it
that way i think there's just got to be
another way to actually
be able to do that that isn't invasive
in people's homes and stuff like that
but i think it's i i feed off of other
people's not necessarily their opinions
but more of their ideas and their you
know their different perspective on what
they're seeing and what i'm making so i
do miss that actually so sure
so
who is an artist that really inspires
you
the artist the artist that i'm into now
is um a motion designer named somme sun
he's a motion designer in china and the
guy's work is
out of this world man like his his
process is crazy too so
what he does for his animatics is
he doesn't do any like drawn animatics
or anything like that he goes and he
finds actual movie clips and he takes
those movie clips and he edits them to
make up the sequence that he wants to
you know create and he shows it to the
client and then he basically for each
shot he rebuilds it in 3d and then
stylize it and then moves for so he'll
take a clip from like you know uh
you know a good fellas uh one shot of
this pan moving or something and then
it'll cut to a shot of a a commercial or
something where he liked this particular
lighting and camera movement and then he
puts music under and i was like that is
a fantastic way to work i mean he's just
he's brilliant and his work is very
polished very clean it's kind of what i
aspire to be like and he's really good
with camera movements in cinema which is
what i struggle with i think a lot of
people struggle with that in 3d um and
he really works like a director of
photography with his cameras so i highly
recommend checking out his work
uh he's not the guy that did carnival
row is he no he did not do uh that um
but he does have this video that he did
for a cell phone company called oppo
find x and i would recommend that it's
on vimeo it's really good so that was
the first piece i saw of his and i've
been
i've been watching his work ever since
so wow
what about is there any particular
studio that really inspires you
yes i would say well there's a lot of
studios that inspire me for sure um i
think the biggest studio
that inspires me is called the artery
i had worked with a musician named jay
views i think it was
oh man it was about
three or four years ago and helped him
out with the music video and did some cg
for him and he introduced me to this one
of the creative directors at this place
called the artery and they do a lot of a
mixture between
cg and live action work and it is
phenomenal like so up there and um i'd
never heard of them before um and
they're up there with like you know um
the mill and stuff like that as far as
quality of work but i don't know if
they're as as known as the mill is but i
love their work they're called the
artery i think it's
a-r-t-e-r-y it's really good stuff yeah
i haven't heard of those guys i'll have
to check them out yeah
um okay so let's switch gears let's go
back to what do you wish you would have
known when you started out in this
industry
um one thing that i wish i would have
known is how important design
fundamentals are um
i kind of just jumped into a dark room
and had to figure it out
a little bit later ended up having to
take a class like i said before much
later in my career to actually fully
understand what is it that i'm missing
um
knowing that there are a lot of content
creators out there that just focus on
design that i could have you know been
using while i was learning all the
technical aspects of cinema 4d and stuff
like that that's side of things that i
really missed out on so
i think people like chris doe i don't
know if you're familiar with him a lot
of the stuff that they do at the future
as far as training the future academy
has been pivotal you know for me as far
as making sure that i'm
i'm a well-rounded designer and i'm not
like just heavy 3d and can't do anything
else so
um when you start i noticed that once i
was just you know
an animator to my team and they were
like well he can't design well well that
was an extra added overhead because we
would have to have one of our designers
come in design it for me so that i can
animate it then once i started designing
myself that actually increased my market
value so i actually ended up making more
money because i could do more work
myself so i wish i would have known to
i took the fundamentals of like editing
and stuff like that but i didn't take
the fundamentals of design and i just
jumped into the field not that there's
anything necessarily wrong with that but
i think you'll have a lot easier path if
you pick up those fundamentals first
especially like the ones you teach at
the beginning of style graph those were
those are a huge help so
yeah it's funny because i was going to
ask you how important do you feel the
design is in motion design because i see
a lot of motion designers who just know
how to do the motion side
yeah and don't understand the design
side
i i think that they are
i think they have to go hand in hand
personally um i've never seen a piece
that was where i said man that was
animated extremely well but the design
sucked you know i was like no that piece
sucked you know like that's pretty much
how it works and vice versa
so i think in order
for your
project to be successful those two have
to have a synergy and it has to be well
balanced one will probably always be a
little bit better than the other one of
the things the director at the film
school said on our first day said in
this industry you're going to walk on
two legs you're going to walk on your
creative leg and you're going to walk on
your technical leg and one's always
going to be longer than the other and
your whole career you're going to be
trying to balance those two and i think
it's the same thing with you it's the
same thing with motion and
design in general you know you can be
very technical but you also want to
bring that design sense with you and
vice versa so yes
100 agree
cool um
how important is it to understand 3d in
today's market as a motion designer
i think it's important
to a sense um
i think it's very important to
understand how 3d works if you're
working with other 3d artists you may
not necessarily be a 3d artist yourself
but understanding their workflow just in
case you guys are put on a project
where your 2d style has to be integrated
with their 3d style which happens a lot
actually and i think it looks phenomenal
especially when those those jobs are
separated when you have one person just
focusing on the 2d and one person
focusing on the 3d so i think it's very
important in that sense and i also think
it's important for just your your
personal market value
um the more skills you learn no matter
what those are that's just going to
increase how much money you can charge
so you know if you if you have you know
the urge to make more money or to do
higher end projects and you say well i
haven't picked up 3d yet it wouldn't
hurt just to take a
month course or two-month course just to
get the basics down and you never know
where that can take you you never know
what
um passion you'll find out of that but
just not to look at it at all i think is
a mistake i think you should definitely
explore all avenues you should be a
learner of life you know what i mean so
any avenue that's going to help you be a
better motion designer i think is very
important so i recently took up
started doing a lot more photography
because that was another aspect that i
felt was lacking in my motion design was
my understanding of how the physics of
optics work even though i understood it
because i read it through books and
stuff like that but i never owned a
camera and picked it up and really went
out and
you know shot footage really
um
so that's been
widely helpful and even at my job now
they're noticing it my boss is my boss
is noticing it and so is the cmo of the
company noticing because i volunteer for
uh some of the uh special interest
groups inside of the entire company so
i'll go to their events and i'll take
photographs and they'll post them on the
company website
and uh the chief marketing officer came
to me he's like wow shannon now you're
taking photos you're doing everything
like yeah you know
that that not only shows that you really
you really are passionate about what
you're doing you're willing to learn
anything that you're you're you you can
it's also showing that
at any point if they give you something
you're willing to sit down and learn it
you know and you know go through the
process get it done and do it well
because you know you have that ability
to learn at any point in time so i think
3d is important but i i don't think it's
i don't think it's a deal breaker in
your career but it's important to
understand how it works definitely
is there a particular 3d package that
you find is you know the superior
package
no i can't say that um i've been hearing
that argument for a long time so my
first 3d application i ever touched was
blender i've also played with maya and
i've done a quite a few things in 3d
studio max and then i've also moved into
as you know i'm mainly seeing them a 4d
now but i also want to move into houdini
at some point
the thing about it is is that all those
softwares are really the damn good
they're all good um it's just that some
does certain things better than others
and that's how those softwares were
built they were built specifically for
certain parts of that industry so if you
look at maya
i feel like maya is the king of king of
character animation um for like major
hollywood films and i think 3d studio
max kind of owns the the video game
world um and i think cinema 4d owns the
motion graphics advertising world and
that's because they were built
specifically for that it's not that one
does better or no one's better than the
others just that you know the tools
inside cinema 4d are mainly geared and
um um i guess
acclimated to work with motion design
advertising quick turnarounds and stuff
like that where the others aren't so
i don't think anyone is better than the
other um it really depends on what
industry you're in i think um i do think
houdini may be the most powerful as far
as just computational-wise the way that
it's built because it's cinema 4d is
still single threaded i think if i'm not
mistaken i don't know if that's changed
yet but
you know you have
just the sheer ability to utilize all of
the
hardware and processing power in your
computer i think houdini may have that
lead but honestly i'm not as much of an
expert on houdini to be able to say
that's true or not i've just heard that
in the ether so
um i yeah no i don't think any one
package is better than the other i think
you can literally jump into any one of
those and be great yeah one's going to
be harder though
a couple will be harder mine is going to
be a little bit harder to just pick up
than cinema 4d for sure yeah
so when you're working with cinema 4d do
you um what's your thoughts on
third-party renderers
well i mean
i love third-party renders so i've used
i've done projects in arnold i've done
projects in octane rich my company now
we're full redshift because of me i was
like no we're going redshift because
before that we were just um standard and
physical
and i was like guys if you want me to
push this we're going to need to get
some we're going to need to get a um a
good render engine in here that can move
fast so
and i've also used of course you know
the physical renderer so and they're all
really great and like i said just like
the 3d software
no no one is better than the other
necessarily it's just that some
render engines do things better than the
other ones do
some of them are a little more optimized
or some give you more control some give
you less control it's it's really up to
you but they're all i like them all but
i would prefer to use octane mainly
because that's where i started so i'm
super familiar with octane because i've
been using it the longest because that
was the first one that was the first gpu
renderer that came out
and i used it right i bought it right
when it came out so that's why i'm so
much more comfortable with it but i'm
trying to get more comfortable with
redshift and i highly recommend like if
you can't afford it i would definitely
recommend doing a gpu render engine
simply for speed purposes um you can get
a lot of great looks i think you can get
phenomenal looks in the physical
renderer and
the pro renderer too which you actually
introduced me to because i wasn't i
didn't really know much about it and i
never played with it i was like i should
have been using this the whole time but
uh
i think i think it's important to
look at every
every possible software that you can get
that can make your workflow faster if
possible if you can afford it of course
sure so what made you pick a redshift
for your team over
octane
so one thing i know about redshift
between octane and redshift that i know
is true and i think um
this was a while ago when i first
started style uh when i first started
starcraft you had talked about this and
then i went and did a little bit more
research on
um redshift being more production ready
than octane which is very true and i
know that from using it now um and i'm
simply doing a lot of reading on it
redshift is
for me at home working on personal
projects and doing any type of freelance
stuff i have the ability to use
something like octane but octane does
have its issues uh especially if you get
down to a sense where
you know you start getting into a
production and then octane just starts
crashing and crashing which happens um
with redshift i don't have that problem
i don't really have a pro and it's just
the way that the two softwares work
redshift is pretty much
built with
um cinema 4d like espresso software so
it's built right from cinema 4d whereas
with octane it has to gather up all your
geometry and then send it to an outside
application and then render it so that
that transfer of that information causes
a lot of problems so that's why it's not
that it's not the best for a production
whereas redshift is so that's why i went
with redshift yeah that makes sense um
going back to you mentioned blender that
you started with blender
i get a lot of questions nowadays about
um the advantages of using blender or
not using it so what can you software
at least i think it's still free
and a lot of
newer newer motion designers are looking
at it because it's a free software and
they do it is a very powerful software
but what would you say
to someone who's thinking about like
should blender be my 3d package i i go
all in with
well i
i can't really say i know that much
about i mean it's literally been about
seven or eight years since i've even
touched blender so
i don't i don't really have enough
knowledge about it to say that that's
that's a accurate statement to make i
think
blender is i know it's very powerful
it's been around for a very long time um
the one thing about open software is
that once you run into issues and things
of that sort of problems
there's no technical support really so
that a lot of which is i think maybe
could be good um you know i think
taking that aspect where there isn't
support where you have to under you have
to learn understand more about the
software to get it to work for you i
think that can be good but can also be a
hindrance because it can take you a
little bit longer to get to the final
thing that you're trying to achieve
but i do think it's a very powerful
software there is something a little bit
wonky about the way you navigate in the
user interface that i didn't like when i
first started using it um
it's kind of like inverted the way it
works if i remember correctly i don't
know if that's changed but other than
that i think the software is extremely
powerful so if that's what gets you in i
would say yeah definitely you know jump
into blender um you can get octane and
redshift and blender and all that stuff
so i'm pretty sure you can
if i'm not mistaken so i would okay i
would say i would say yeah jump into
blender if that's your if that's your
access to the industry do it definitely
um if that can get you in
absolutely jump into i've seen some
phenomenal work out of blender
even when i first i didn't even know
what it was and i first started looking
into it 10 years ago the work they were
making in blender was absolutely amazing
so
um
i think it's a great software i would
say definitely explore it if you can
yeah okay
is there a or do you have a favorite
plugin or script that you like to go to
my favorite
plugin let's see here and this could be
2d or 3d
so my my favorite plug-in definitely is
x-particles for sure um
and i'm hoping at some point near you
know down in the future i can do some ex
particle training um for style or for
pro flows i think they would enjoy that
i know that's a not as easy attainable
as a software um but it is very powerful
and it's really cool it's a software
inside of it but there's
literally unlimited things you can do
with it and that's kind of what i want
to go into is more like particle
dynamics particle simulations and stuff
like that i really enjoy that stuff so
um that's my favorite plugin to go to
for sure other than you know my render
engine of course so right
so what uh
when you say that you want to go into
particle systems and things like that
like what is it more visual effects
based or what is that
yeah so um have you have you ever heard
of the guide name i'm sure you've seen a
lot of work from man versus machine
right and you've seen network that type
of stuff like that type of simulation
and and that's the kind of style i want
to go with um
let me see here i'm trying to think of
another example it's really
yeah i can't think of another example
i'll have to send you some of what i'm
talking about but it's yeah it's just
anything that has to do with particles
really i enjoy so
um creating smoke creating explosions
making car paint melt off of a car you
know
i actually did a course with the guy
allen mckay where we did the thanos
disintegration effect where we you know
how in the movie he makes everybody else
disintegrate on this one he showed you
how to make thanos disintegrating we had
to do that in 3d studio max
um and i just love the hell out of that
so that's the type of stuff i want to do
yeah
so do you ever do um do you ever play
around with particle systems and after
effects like with stardust or trap code
yeah man i love trap code i love i think
stardust is the next level man i think
uh
i think that's more powerful than
trapcode in my opinion now i haven't
used
stardust as much as i've used trapcode
i've just seen what it can do and that
it's a node based system and i'm like
dude that's that's it right there you
know i can have multiple systems on one
layer that's phenomenal so
um yeah i think stargate stardust is
great i don't know how much it's used
though um i don't know how much people
are actually using it i don't really
hear much about it but
it's a phenomenal plug-in yeah yeah i
find the same thing it's like i still go
back to trap code when i have to do
particle systems because i understand it
but then i own stardust and it's like i
see the power in that and and the thing
the examples i've seen of what people
creating with it uh to me it's just it's
more and i'm not bashing anybody but
it's like just like these social media
posts that people are like hey look what
i created you know and it's just like
okay well what's where is the practical
type of you know how can this actually
be used in like a you know a production
but i haven't really seen much of that
and no one like you said not a lot of
people talk about it so yeah it's hard
to say
well maybe that's something we can do in
the future is i can start exploring that
plug-in a little bit more if your um
subscribers or your users are
wanting to learn more about that i can
figure out a way to actually
you know make that into a
workshop that they may enjoy i would
love to dive in and just learn that
plug-in just to see what it can do but
yeah like you said i don't know if it's
production ready and i'd be willing to
let them know like hey guys no this is
good for experimental stuff but not not
for production so we'll we'll have to
look into that maybe yeah that'd be
awesome yeah um okay so we're gonna wrap
this up here in just a minute i wanna
ask you just a couple more questions one
of those is
where do you see the future of motion
design going
yeah that's uh i see
well i mean it's a lot of the things
that i was saying two years ago or two
or three years ago with motion design is
already happening so i mean it's
everywhere so it's kind of hard to see
where it's not going um
i
was recently
called by a company or called by a
company called davida and they are a
kidney dialysis company and they need
motion designers and it's like they're
one of the largest kidney dialysis
companies in the in the world and they
need motion designers and then you know
you have vr you have ar
um
motion design is
extremely or it's very prevalent in film
now it wasn't as much so in the 90s now
you know you got user interfaces you
have title sequences which i love
um
so now it's becoming way more integrated
into that now it's in the medical
industry where you know you have medical
animations for doctors and and bio bio
um chemists and things of that sort so
really it's like where is it not going
really i mean it's it's going everywhere
everybody needs it so
um i would say there's not gonna be any
industry that motion design won't be a
big part of
just i just don't see it people are more
visual now that everybody's on their
screen so you need guys like us or guys
and gals like us to you know make that
imagery look beautiful you know and make
it move so
i don't see where it's not going
honestly yeah i 100 agree
100
all right so where if people want to
know more about shannon wilkerson where
can they see your work
um the best place to see my work is uh
like if i'm doing any type of
experimental work or work in progress is
my instagram and it's just the
underscore underscore shannon wilkerson
and then two more underscores after that
and then just shannonwilkerson.com is
what my website is i haven't updated it
in a while um which i need to do uh you
actually reminded me of that
in the facebook message you sent me so
i'm gonna do that here shortly and get
some of my newer projects on there but
uh yeah those are the two best places to
find me yeah awesome
all right man well i appreciate you
being on the show today this was an
amazing interview um full of like some
really good ted bits man some really
good information there so i i really
appreciate you being on the show today
and uh
have a good one youtube cameron thank
you all right man
[Music]
you